let me let me pull up the story we got
from timcast.com transportation
secretary buddha judge says supply chain
disruptions could continue into 2022. so
we we just found out that apparently he
was like a two month leave no one knew
while the crisis is happening we're
wondering like how did this happen well
the guy who's supposed to be running
that isn't here for one thing but
actually before the show you brought up
a really good point about this so i have
a chapter in the book called biden inc
and it talks about all the people
that got confirmed and didn't that we
don't know about and when i say that is
frankly i don't think republicans did
their job during the confirmation
process but check this out pete
butterjudge is 38 years old he was the
mayor of south bend indiana that has a
hundred thousand people and do you know
how many buses they have 66 million 66
million 66 buses
there's 66 buses in a city of okay and
that's who he chose to lead the airways
the railways the seaports all of these
things are being run by a guy that's 38
years old that oversaw 66 buses let's be
real buddha judge dropped out through
his support behind biden right gave a
kickback but here's the kicker so when
biden when he was confirmed
right and i talk about this in the book
that the first thing biden says is i'm
excited to have the most qualified guy
no he says i'm excited to have the first
openly gay
cabinet member to lead a department and
they said that because grinnell had been
dni but that's not the point the point
is when grinnell got hired by trump it
was because he was qualified because he
had the experience when bootage got
hired it was because he checked a box
not because he was qualified i feel like
you know i see i see buddha judge and
they make that announcement he's at the
first gay department and i'm like wow
that's that that's really cool like
congratulations to buddhijet on his
family and his love and his and his
children uh
so what experience and work do you have
yeah like look the social stuff aside we
can be like that's nice yeah i mean
that's why i think biden doesn't care
about his legacy he has a guy that's
arguing arguing with tucker carlson
about a male breastfeeding right now
that's the argument what he wants to do
because to him it's more important to
say i checked a box who did i appoint
not what did i get done think about this
real quick kamala harris she got zero
delegates right yeah so he chooses her
she's not again a popular person
but what did he say not that i want the
best qualified vp that can step in and
be president i want to have the first
woman and i'm going to choose someone of
color so he immediately says it's not
about qualifications i the other person
that i really delve into and there's a
lot of them but one of my favorites is
dennis mcdonough he's the head of he's
the secretary of veterans affairs never
served in the military didn't work with
veterans groups and doesn't have
anything to do with health care right
the only other person in the history of
the united states that hasn't been a
veteran that was secretary was david
shulkin who had served in obama trump
kept him he's a doctor he worked in the
va he understands health care
specifically veterans health care right
va health care systems how it's
delivered etc dennis mcdonough had no
experience except he had been obama's
chief of staff that's it but those are
the kind of people that we're putting in
place and we wonder why we are where we
are
this a point that i have made because we
are looking at a social justice checking
the box for demographics administration
you're seeing it play out this is what's
happening
though that this is their metric yes if
you're on the left it's not what did you
get done it's how many boxes did you
check how many firsts how many things
did you can we say that you did so that
you know it's it's how much critical
race theory did you inject into the
system how many of these you know uh
welfare programs did you start but it's
all about being able to to lay a marker
down for the progressive left going
forward it's a cult
that's what happens when you let an
authority run the show all the time i
think that's why this decentralized
united states is so important and why
the private sector is such a big part of
our lifestyle because you can't let some
central organization pick all the pieces
and parts every time if because
eventually you're going to get some
ideas but one of the one of the points
that i touch on in the book is this you
have to understand what i call the why
right there's a chapter in here about dc
and people have to understand this
because this is so fundamental to what
the democrats believe the district of
columbia was created by our framers a 10
square mile district they took apart
from virginia and apart from maryland
and created dc when they no longer
needed the part from virginia they gave
it back i live in that part right now in
virginia that used to be the part of the
district
well now democrats go around they say we
want the people in dc to have voting
rights oh that sounds so american
everybody should be able to vote great
but my answer is well then give back the
part in dc to maryland that's no longer
being used because gosh we did that to
virginia we took it from maryland give
back what's no longer needed it's
already a state problem solved but what
do democrats want to do they want to
create a state among these few hundred
thousand people why
why because d.c votes 95 to 5 democrat
meaning that you will have two more
democratic senators in perpetuity they
they like to talk about how oh these red
states like wyoming
delaware huh come on you want to make
delaware is microscopic right but the
point is is that the democrats have an
overarching goal which is to maintain
political power as long as they can so
that they have a vehicle to push these
power these policies through and once
you understand that that these people
and these policies are all there for
that same collective reason then you get
it and this is like the great reset
using the american democratic party
is this sure but they all get it the
more people that are addicted to
government the more that they enact
policies that ensure that they never out
you you mentioned you know you know
biden basically hires people with no
experience like i said you know booty
just probably just uh here's your
kickback thanks for throwing your weight
behind us but i kind of feel like you
know donald trump had some people who
should not have been there under the
assumption that experience i think he
thought john bolton was going to give
him good advice and that was a mistake i
think he thought millie was going to
give him good advice and that was a
mistake so i wonder if trump would have
been better off with a bunch of randoms
that didn't have experience in the long
run well to some degree
we kind of started that way i mean you
think about it trump look if you go back
looking through every other candidate in
history they were either a politician a
general they had a group of people
around them especially in modern times
if you're a governor or senator you've
got advisors and consultants and donors
they can fill spots trump was a
businessman he wasn't a politician so he
comes into office he's like hey i'm
gonna grab that guy that guy that guy
some of them fit well some of them
didn't but he had to go through that
churn initially because he didn't have a
whole group of people that were
part of his donors but there were some
people that joe biden has the entirety
of the establishment behind him is the
best he could do right but but the
difference is
that
he has the people he's putting him in
the wrong places right so it's not that
pete buddha jesus is a dumb guy or
couldn't do something in the
administration it's that they put him in
a place that he's not qualified dennis
mcdonough is not a bad guy he's a smart
guy from everything i know but he
shouldn't be leading the department of
veterans affairs i mean he could have
been omb or something he's got
government experience
of management budget i mean he was
obama's chief of staff he he gets
government he's not a dumb guy but the
point isn't that they're not smart it's
that they're not qualified for the jobs
they're in this is why i think you know
joe biden's in charge you know some
people want to play it out like he's
secretly not running the show kamala's
no i think you've got a bunch of
sycophants who are sitting around being
like sure thing joe unqualified people
and no one wants to challenge him the
dude's out of his mind he probably
mutters and spurs out gibberish we hear
him say it on tv when he mutters off my
favorite was when he was saying
something and then he went
whatever just like stop deadness tricks
and look with all due respect he's an
old guy he's losing it but i genuinely
believe he's sitting in these cabinet
meetings and he's like uh carmilla can
you uh uh the border uh
uh
uh
oh
i'm gonna go to i'm gonna go to bed and
then she's like i don't know what i'm
doing what am i doing and then the media
is like where's kamala harris and she's
like i don't know what i'm doing i would
disagree especially when we look at
what's been happening because when you
see the policies and who they directly
affect they affect middle america uh
people in the lower class that are
absolutely being obliterated the
billionaire class they're getting richer
than they ever have been in recorded
human history yeah there's a chart going
around right now i mean you could always
ask who you know who benefits i always
ask that just because no one's on duty
and so the leaders are looting no no no
no i think the looters are looting more
than they ever have because of the
policies that they're implementing that
directly benefit them uh there's a new
chart going around right now that says
in the united states the top one percent
now holds more money and more wealth
than all of the middle class combined so
so when we were seeing such a huge
transfer of wealth when we were seeing
the american people just thrown down the
toilet being mandated being restricted
being regulated being taxed more than
ever who do these policies directly
benefit a lot of the multinational
corporate billionaires that of course
have financed him have put him into
office and now they're getting the
rewards with the policies that he puts
forward and i think he's too delusional
i don't think he's there i think they're
the ones saying do this for us because
we got you in there and he's like yes
sir whatever you want here's this deal
here's this package here's this contract
here's this new regulation here's this
new tax which will make you win which
will give you money and screw everyone
else over so i pulled up this chart from
business insider and you can see that
for the first time it appears or not
from the first time but at least in the
span of this chart that the top one
percent now surpassed the middle 60
percent
i don't know if i you know agree on
necessarily what joe biden is doing but
i will say that the establishment elites
as a whole definitely want to create a
class system where the poor working
class never move up eliminate upward
mobility basically just have ultra
elites who are wealthy will always be
wealthy if you if you're rich and you're
born rich stay rich
why why why why risk it now for me
that's not a policy about someone caring
about his legacy that's a policy of a
sinking ship the ship's going down and
we're going down with it very fast look
at the way china has been
establishing their policies their
foreign policy their domestic trading
systems their uh belt and road
initiatives it's completely 100 percent
80 uh
you know degrees different than what
we're doing here in the united states
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you